hey yo what's up y'all know it is two
boys Aquos and this is GQ on the rocks
take one I mean my first like real piece
of Julian the Iron Man game you know
giving my GTV China held my first cars
real China the GTV bomb originating on a
bit
adela the chain that let you know you
was really raised a gang like you got
one of those Chinese you know you was
really a fish young dog rich homie Quan
ha boy
[Music]
well a lot of my Giri I was gifted he
got stoled I took a trip to Germany and
Stella had gave me two new chains the
refugees broken our car
yeah and they stole my chair but
Herman's gave me another chain original
chain RG crazy guy did the new bridge
again pieces
it's just a small I got artist beach so
I needed some little yeah yeah shout out
the stunning I'll let you down thank you
doctor I get a girlfriend I'm a little
with ya under target
[Music]
this is my favorite I was exactly sure
this lizard I did a lot in this sense I
got mine I first got I got mine I walked
in the jury stone icebox looked out for
me a little bit and showed me some love
on the price you know then shut out
icebox this when I first started getting
money I told him I wanted to change my
name on it
even yeah that's my signature I came
home with my signature honestly uh I
don't know one day I was in high school
they put me on ISS like in-school
suspension I don't know why the [ __ ]
they put me in that and I just had a
white piece of paper and I was just
write my name like Kevin won't come
around my neck then I figured out and I
remember my ISS teacher she kept that
paper too that's just I think she framed
it so like I can be scheduled a lot of
my teachers on cuz when I was coming up
my teachers they helped me though you
know they're like and my teachers always
around me like for my 24th birthday
party it was all at my party but they
still my teachers like they still
educate me off on life in Arlen if I
reach her like you made this fyb this my
is my crew my label no sighs I signed my
first artist to cash money that's us
right there this is actually another one
right here
yeah Vee
I paid seven thousand three men to get
this one man but I only pay photons me
get this with me yeah I understand it
[Music]
this will pay 18,000 for this chain okay
like 7,000 8,000 foot a billion piece
beats nap abroad next it's my last night
yeah the guy's just oh yeah the diamonds
can breathe a little bit
I got a bit so that's really why I got
it I want to match it this year this
been my biggest year Bravo like Oh cause
this is about her are about a lambo last
year I bought the Bentley about my mama
so she this is because I'm feeling about
me something else
this front of my favorite chair I know I
got this yeah I paid 25 pounds for this
he got a big buck on I like the lock on
her just like my first cute yeah the
watch I got this from jury unlimited
shout out to my boy over there maybe
show love he got good prices - I felt
like 35,000 foot is like it's super
pretty and it's nothing his my stylist
for so long I won't wear no roses like
if you gonna look at my shoulders
everything I was saying roll the wrists
on the [ __ ] I got [ __ ] on my wrist
you know ain't cuz I had lost my rollin
in Miami feeling when I got back to the
crib I like damn I was wrong but you
know now I got insurance on on my jury
make sure you ain't sure your jury
people he got jury making a shady [ __ ]
I'm work hard too so I deserved an
something like this on artists people
see you in a Rolex you gonna show your
show prize my god it's a party an image
I did [ __ ] don't mean enemy I love it
your mouth yo my [ __ ] right
150 you don't want it is how I see my
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got this one touches jury
that's a place in Detroit and this was a
day before my birthday and I wanted to I
wanted to ring it she was like 5,000
betta goetta took like three he shot me
luck on my birthday baby show look I got
these two from lucky I had to get them
together cuz I ain't like how I look
separate like it's like you got to put
them on together for the
I do wear it separately what kind of
Connie and then this one's too big for
my fingers oh I have to block it would I
paint like 2,000 feet studies you didn't
say like okay I got this from lucky to
this like my favorite right now
cuz you got diamonds everywhere this is
my first set of will get like that's my
[ __ ] they call you downs you know pay
like 8,000 artists jury like this got
like locks on snaps all time she so you
want to lose it he's like some security
customership you know people don't
really wear one earring on mobile when I
wear my gold said I want every yeah
here's one in the meadow there's some
some crush no [ __ ] on the spot I lost of
them
I just kept up with the n DS my earrings
i well I shot at Jerry on there
he was like to a p5 well I pierced my
left ear when I was six and then two
years after that my mama let me pierce
my right here that was the room you know
that's what [ __ ] you gotta be ready for
you know I she change her whole style
when you get your ear Chris I'm gonna
the young English entering the room and
I hear she was a problem well I had a
perm back camber so you got to think
well I thought I was playing about real
[Music]
shout out a two part two parking spot I
got my nose perfect 2011
[Music]
Oh 4235 lost nc2 man's everywhere right
now go get it if you passed a local
target go buy my album if you want to
internet go get lost at sea to my new
album coming out 2019 and I have a whole
bunch of new jury so be looking out for
2019 is gonna be crazy I was having more
glasses on the way that's giving